you see you're like a rejuvenated man
you you're [ __ ] hitting lunches you
know
brown rice and [ __ ] chickens oh
that's really good that uh asian box but
no it's uh she finished her second year
on saturday so we ordered a pizza and we
got high and we [ __ ] ate a dessert
and just hung out watched three hours of
shark tank and passed out by the name
i uh i had cinnamon rolls i had those
pillsbury cinnamon rolls did you make
them fresh oh yeah in the oven oh yeah
you have to and you got extra cream and
smearing out those [ __ ] not an
extra cream but just yeah just the
shitty cream they give you where do you
get extras cream from because you want
to don't worry you gotta make a few
calls to craft what the [ __ ] makes them
you joke that like my sweat smells like
cheeseburgers but on the elliptical
today i'm convinced i was burning like a
mcdonald's cheeseburger off from a long
time ago because it smelled like a
cheeseburger but you know when the
pickles and the ketchup get hot and it
like has it oh i was convinced on the
elliptical like why do i smell like a
mcdouble you could smell oh i couldn't
you could smell the pickle juice coming
out of the pickle and ketchup yeah
that's amazing this [ __ ] smell
when was the last time you ate
mcdonald's over six months ago so it's
been yeah you just caught like a little
piece of fat in the armpit that had the
[ __ ] pickle in there i think so yeah
tremendous man i'm happy that
everything's working out
uh you had a great weekend i was in
[ __ ] grand rapids great club great
audiences the food at this place they
got a salmon they got a beautiful salmon
and a better tortellini with green
peppers red peppers a little goat cheese
cream
that'll put you in a different
dimensionally a little bit of tortellini
too i love tortillas
no it's gnocchi oh no a little potato in
it and they [ __ ] just delicious you
understand me just off the [ __ ] chain
delicious the shows were great i thought
my thursday show was men's and mortar
but it was good
friday my best show was saturday early
friday late that crazy i'm crazy the
timing's off but [ __ ] we make it work
you know but i had a great time that's a
great little city that is a great great
little city i bet you know
i'm really happy because the places i go
that i really want to go to and i really
enjoy them there's maybe one or two
things you know i don't even eat in
these cities no more
what do you mean like you know i don't
know i think the last time i went to
buffalo i only had three wings yeah like
at the club one night you know i just
really don't like i've been there so
many times i see it
remember i was telling you that i had
the chubby state of mind mentality that
everywhere you go the first thing you
think of is food like some people think
oh my god when i go to this place i'm
the first thing i'm gonna go is go to
this library or go to this museum i like
it there's a coffee shop that makes my
latte you know guys like you and i think
about [ __ ] there's a place on the corner
and make barbecue i'm gonna go have two
[ __ ] barbecue sandwiches i'm gonna
try to go home for a sec like a weekend
this summer to boston and i've my mom
and i already planning what i'm gonna
eat what are you gonna eat we're gonna
go to legals which is one of my
favorites and then there's a really
great barbecue place right where i used
to go when i was in high school i'm
going to go to
and that's and then
it's uh it's crazy how much
i never like mother's day is great
but i wanted to talk to you about it
because
paula's mom is like the first mom of any
girlfriend i've been like tight with
and like yesterday i gave her a card and
we were going to a dodgers game on
thursday
and she got really like she got really
emotional we and we can't really talk
because she doesn't speak english
but like i can imagine mother's day for
you
like after your mom passed away must
have been [ __ ] up but then you
probably had other people who took that
place
yeah like yesterday even when i was
having a [ __ ] up day i made some calls
from mother's day yeah people who
uh were nice to me growing up and they
got a kick out of the call
but it's funny every mother's day yes i
think about my mother but i also think
about
the mother to my ex-wife
you know uh
she was real i so that's why i
understand where you're coming from yeah
i was thinking about a fight we had one
time that could have really been bad
you know i don't believe in setting the
crib up until the baby's born it's just
a superstition that cubans have maybe a
couple of
other cultures have i'm just [ __ ]
superstitious like you think something
bad could happen once the baby's born
then you build the crib he's not gonna
be home for two [ __ ] days anyway you
come home you build a crib it takes one
[ __ ] hour no
that's the only beef we ever had her and
i we had a beef about a crib one time
that escalated a little bit
and i walked out of the room because i
didn't want to blow it up but
my mother-in-law was very cool when i
got to my first job selling cars i
didn't have clothes she gave me her visa
card
and said go use it and just pay me what
you can every week and i paid off like
600 bucks i had to get a couple suits
and some shirts
she used to cook special for me she knew
i liked pierogies the sauerkraut ones
and oh wow so that's it's you know
growing up you always hear people
comedians and people on tv the comedies
towards the mother-in-law you hate the
mother-in-law you hate the mother-in-law
you hate the mother-in-law but once you
have a mother-in-law
see to me like even terry's mother
terry's mother and i are close to an
extent but i know
when i'm with terry's mother i know that
she likes me because
she looks at her daughter and she sees a
smile on her face right see that's why
this woman loves you because
you're making a daughter happy you're
acting like a gentleman in her [ __ ]
home you show respect in her home and a
lot of guys just
you know yeah guys do it but it's it's
it's weird to date somebody and it's
weird to date somebody and become a part
of that family it's a complete different
experience especially when you're a
young man and you
you know you always have uh thoughts
about living with somebody like the
first time i moved in with a woman that
was big for me oh yeah i'm still haven't
done it like i was uh 25 it was like a
different thing you try to keep cool
but there's nothing you could do it's
just an evolution you just evolve into a
girl being in your house now you lived
with guys
and now you have this woman who lives
with you and you try to do things and
you become best friends with her you
don't but it always evolves you know but
that relationship with young laws i
still remember my ex-in-law dad
he really dug me him and i had become a
great relationship he was a
pseudo-father to me
in a different genre carmine was a
father to me mr bender was a father to
me you know mr ronnie was a father to me
mr holloway was a father to me but
he was a different father to me in a
different genre he didn't have that
mindset he made me read books he spoke
to me about history when i went to when
i got arrested for kidnapping he came
and bailed me out and spoke to me and
asked me what happened
and to tell him the truth and i told him
the truth
and it was weird because i had dated his
daughter for four years
and we were always on a very 50 50 type
relationship and once i got arrested he
showed his true colors to me and i could
show my true colors to him
and it really changed our relationship i
would go up there on the weekends and
help him cut wood
and we'd speak about his life and
history and what my thoughts were and
how i was going to achieve the things i
wanted
and
sometimes i think that the only reason
why i didn't go off in bolder was
because of him i didn't want to
disrespect him
and his wife or what they had done for
me because even though me and his
daughter weren't together they did a lot
for me man i always respected that
of people when somebody does something i
never wanted them to feel like i was i
used them you know that was always very
important to me if you've been used you
know the feeling it's a shitty feeling
and you never look at that person again
who uses you you know right so i always
wanted to give people let them know that
what they contributed to my life
i took into consideration in my future
decisions that's why i made those calls
to some of my friends moms yesterday and
like
paula's mom has been broke forever all
her life and so like i i got her a card
and i went to portals and got her
favorite cake
and
i could tell that that meant more to her
than if i had like let's say like
like let's say when i bought her like
diamond earrings or just something i'm
sure some guys do and like you wouldn't
cut wood with your father-in-law you
probably could have paid you had three
sons yeah and his sons overlooked that
fact right
you know maybe uh your mother-in-law has
other boys two other sons and one of
them couldn't show up because he went to
the wife's house yeah
it's uh and that's what probably
happened yeah i don't even know this
it's really weird when uh
and and i see the change that paula and
her family has had on you they've had a
really
great effect on you in the sense that
it's brought you back to basics it was
the same effect
that i had when i was growing up and i
used to go to 148th street you see how
the other side lives sometimes you have
a bad day
and you dab and also you think about
paula how they didn't have an air
conditioner
they don't even know what that world is
like they just didn't have air
conditioners they had fans
right spanish people they had fans
and they still don't want to turn the ac
on but at least they haven't they don't
even they don't even think about it they
live so long without it right that
they've learned how to adjust
and when you see that you see how
spoiled we are as people i've always
talked about that when you see a when
you see a woman at 10 o'clock you know
pull up with her range rover and i just
left yoga my day is so stressful you
know i dropped the kids off no you
didn't the nanny dropped the kids off
and went you went to yoga with your
range rover and now you went to uh latte
ville to tell them all what a big day
you have and but what about that lady
that's taking care of your [ __ ] kids
all day what about the spanish woman
that like i told you a thousand times
i'm victory and violent by the [ __ ]
target over there walking across the
street pregnant with a kid in the bucket
and one in the [ __ ] hand growing
across [ __ ] violin with 10 shopping
bags you think she walks around saying
my feet hurt yoga no [ __ ] no
so it makes you humble and makes you see
what people can do and how the other
side lives right and the things that you
thought were just impossible and now you
see it you never dreamt of living with
four people in your [ __ ] bedroom
never
never when i was growing up i never when
my mother died the thought of having to
share a bedroom was incomprehensible to
me like it was incomprehensible but that
death
brought me back eleanor's got a great
joke
uh she says that um that's special she
says that rich people
you know poor people don't have food
allergies
yeah
you know poor people do not have food
allergies okay you think you go over
there and one of those kids are allergic
to peanuts the cheese juice
they just don't you really see how the
other half lives you see what you can
live without this is what happened when
my mother died this is when i said to
you like i always saw what i could do
without
that's why i'm the way i am like i don't
give a [ __ ] like i always thought you
had to be there at midnight to watch the
movie what if you missed it you wake up
the next morning life is still the same
light and you see life from a different
perspective because you weren't part of
a sheep [ __ ] movement
it's really weird to say no one to go
against something you really want to do
but when you do it you see the other
side you see how the other side lives
you always realize what's important now
holy [ __ ] i see what's [ __ ] important
and what i've found at least and let's
try listen hold on one second
right now auntie dolores uh sent us the
new packaging today she thought this
cocoa cookies she sent us caramel corn
this is the new packaging and she sent
us uh
savory pretzels as you know auntie
dolores is the leader
you know in vegan sugar-free
snacks and she's the the leader in death
she also sent us a 30 milligram edible
that we'll eat right now let's have the
the caramel corn what are you gonna take
there
oh you want to do the brownie okay
that's a little brownie though
that's gonna be very special
it's just myself and leap
so we're going to have a little [ __ ]
smorgasbord here tonight
i'll just talk some [ __ ] with you people
you know what i'm saying just uh
very simple about what's going on we've
had reagan in here and the football
player and
every once in a while we just want to
talk [ __ ] and for you guys just to tap
into our conversation and see what the
[ __ ] we're feeling and what we're doing
i'm sorry let's interrupt you no it's
okay i'm just thinking i'm glad i ubered
um
oh
so you're just saying like what you
realize you can live without
i used to go every year to my my friend
my dad's friend's christmas party
and they're super rich and they had
someone dressed up as santa and they had
all this gifts and all that sort of
stuff it was always fun
the best christmas i've ever had
was the first year the first christmas
with paula and her mom
it was me her her mom and her cousin
we did gifts
we did food and tamales
and then we got drunk and played loteria
and they're like in their house in
englewood and it was great like it's
just
it's simple yeah it's simple
there's no uh fakeness there's no
you know they
i like chris i tell you one of the best
christmases i had was my christmas in
prison
it was the best christmas i ever had
because it broke it down to the simplest
of what christmas was
you know that we exchanged gifts yeah i
gave one guy a comb
i gave the other guy like [ __ ]
batteries you know
but it was about food it was about guys
being together locked up and making the
best of what they had
and when you do that sometimes it's a
different holiday it adds a different
[ __ ] twist to everything
you know i've always been a spokesman
against weddings
it's not that i hate marriages and
whatever
i just don't at a point it becomes like
you're getting married for somebody else
oh yeah totally i want you to get
married for you
when i got married the first time i got
married for me but it was for her
parents
when i got married to terry it was about
us
it was about what we wanted how we
wanted to do it
you know what we wanted people to wear
which was regular [ __ ] we did it on a
wednesday
it was a wedding did anybody did you get
any [ __ ] like how could you not be doing
this or how
people know better to say something
with you they don't care
you know yeah i'll break it down for you
everybody's here on wednesday
everybody's everybody's here what's the
busiest night in the college town in any
town
the night before thanksgiving oh yeah
everybody goes everybody wears their
nice shirts they're home from college
college is great you should where you
going to school um i took the semester
off oh yeah what and they make you feel
bad biggest night of the [ __ ] year
thanksgiving biggest night of the
[ __ ] year you know so that's why oh
is that when you did it what's that the
wedding you're winning yeah i did it
before thanksgiving the wednesday before
thanksgiving
did it on wilshere in a little office
building and once you open it looks like
a [ __ ] church
filipinos and immigrants get married in
there little pre-shows up we took the
third floor penthouse suite if you over
6-2 you banged your head on the ceiling
but you had a great time like i've seen
my pictures mike kessler walked
my wife down you know it was it was red
band and ari with a suit ari wore a suit
and gave me a present and uh we got
married and we when we raced up to the
hollywood bowl and we got
[ __ ] white rice black beans and pork
chunks from silver lake or cochinito and
we got pastrami sandwiches from wangas
with a bunch of rye bread and then we
got [ __ ] fried chicken from rouse
and we got sodas and we bought a bunch
of booze you can make your own drink
and that's it i didn't care what you
wore i didn't care who you brought
my wife made a mini a wedding cake
overnight she stayed up all night making
it my wife got high
she put a dress on i put a suit on and
we got married her parents didn't show
my family didn't come
it was i and i didn't care
i understand i'm not there to get
married for people i'm gonna get married
for myself if you i never held a grudge
against people ebay didn't go a lot of
people ralphie didn't go they were
working i got it i wasn't mad
i had to do it that day i did not want
to do it on a saturday and
you know make a big to-do i just wanted
to [ __ ] get married and look we're
still together we're gonna go on 15
years i love him more than ever i didn't
get married i remember years ago the
black chick from the view got married to
some [ __ ] black dude and they [ __ ]
had chris rock there and the chubby
black girl what's her name
no the one before sherry sheppard i'll
look it up okay she got married she lost
a lot of weight and blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah
and the guy [ __ ] some [ __ ] uh
whatever the chick from uh dirt
uh whatever desperate housewives they
had a 10 million dollar wedding with the
basketball player from the spurs
the [ __ ] black guy that lost his edge
and all of a sudden they got married
everybody loved each other and what
happened boom he [ __ ] the housekeeper
you know a guy listen that's all that
[ __ ] is to entangle glasses and for your
friends to come and say it was elegant
not the other day nobody gives a [ __ ]
they're all there for the [ __ ] free
meal
so and to be seen and to be heard that's
why that celebrity [ __ ] is [ __ ] to
me every time i see a celebrity get
married it's it's garbage it's like
you know i love him and you don't you
don't even love yourself you're fake you
don't even write your own [ __ ] lines
you piece of [ __ ] you expect to [ __ ]
love somebody get the [ __ ] out of here
what's up lisa you bad [ __ ] this
brownie
hit
hard right away i don't know if it's a
green hornet or what we don't [ __ ]
around we got we also have it we're
gonna do a little caramel corn and
sample that okay the caramel corn is
delicious we're gonna do one of these
[ __ ] black mambos the cocoa sparkles
and listen people know i really don't i
usually don't like brownies like
anything with chocolate with weed is
usually not my favorite
that is the br that brownies i almost
couldn't taste the wheat you can still
taste it i could tell on your face that
you didn't [ __ ] sour and [ __ ] around
and want another thing lee let these
people know
whether it's anarchy edibles
chiba chews
or auntie dolores they have always been
my go-to edibles i mean i just
discovered anarchy edibles and i think
they're brilliant i got i still got the
star there we ate all that [ __ ]
edibles great product i like who runs i
love his story well the thing that you
taught me is you really have to switch
it up because i don't know how many
milligrams that brownie was it's less
than the star yes but since i haven't
had anything like that for a while it's
hitting me [ __ ] it's a different
batch it's a different factor when you
eat chibachu they have that type of
butter i guess when you eat their stuff
they have their time you go on rotations
dude sure because you don't even want to
it's like working out you want to run
one week you want to do kettlebells one
week you want to bodybuild one week you
want to go to jiu jitsu one week you
always keep it up so your muscles are
always i swam on friday lee i went to
the [ __ ] thing i put my [ __ ]
lifting suit on and i went downstairs
and as i walked down the pool was empty
i knew that saturday the pool was going
to be filled with [ __ ] kids
i went upstairs i wanted my little
utility bag where i got an extra sleep
apnea i get everything like sugars you
know those cancer sugars you save sugars
oh i have to just in case i go to a
hotel room and i make coffee and they
got no [ __ ] sugar so i have
everything in there
okay i got everything [ __ ] in there i
went upstairs i got the goggles i ran
down i jumped in the pool i was doing
laps
breaststroke and kicking
on the way in and i'm just pulling
myself on the way back i would do that
five times and then walk around the pool
or run around the pool and throw side
kicks and the pool was four foot six so
it was from my [ __ ] chest down
i did that for half hour i'm not going
to want to know but i stayed in the pool
for a half hour and i stayed in the
jacuzzi for like 20 minutes you can do
five back and forth yeah that's hard but
i know how to breathe i learned how to
breathe with swimming the first two
times i did i almost had drowned i don't
i don't remember
and breathe when your head goes in when
you do a breaststroke when you do this
one coming around you twist your head on
this arm yeah and you breathe
and as you throw that arm you breathe
out so when you pop up again you breathe
out you have to breathe out when you hit
the water you breathe out in the water
you exhale
so right here
and as you hit it's all timed it's a
beautiful thing swimming is a beautiful
thing when you see those guys [ __ ]
doing i can't do the butterfly me
neither but when you see them doing the
butterfly when they're on the way up
they're inhaling when they hit the water
they exhale when they pop out they
inhale they can't breathe under the
water so you might as well exhale it and
use that power you know you have to put
your fingers together to grab
so all those little
intricate things when you do a little
breath because i can't do a uh
a regular breaststroke anymore because
of my shoulders but i could do the pull
from the bottom if i had the pulleys i
would put those between my legs then you
float and that gets your core and you
just [ __ ] pull your shoulders get
strong it loosens everything up in here
you don't need no 20 massages from
chinese woman obviously i don't know
much about toning but i've heard like
that swimming is the best thing for like
building muscle well the problem with
swimming is that it's a great exercise
you burn a lot of calories while you're
in the water and you burn a great cardio
but when you get out of the pool that's
it it doesn't stay with you the rest of
the day as if weight lifting would or
run when you run it you weight lift
those calories burn throughout the day
the elliptical those calories burn
throughout the day that's when you want
to go early and eat your carbs for the
day early and it gets it out of the way
by the way i'm down to 305. nice job 20
[ __ ] pounds on this little [ __ ]
diet [ __ ] do you somebody sent me
another thing about the
operation that after nine years
you start losing your teeth because your
body doesn't get the nutrients that it
has to you have to constantly drink
milkshakes and milk and protein and this
and that and get sun so i think i'm
going to stick with what i'm doing right
now it's working for me i feel [ __ ]
great i deadlifted today i did all my
upper lower end i did the elliptical
today i sweat like a [ __ ] sandwich
very humid in los angeles yeah
what's up [ __ ] what are you looking at
me like that for
because i'm [ __ ] high as [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah that's what we're supposed to be
that's what we do to church
of what's [ __ ] happening now
[ __ ] what else i had a fucked-up
thing happen on friday what happened to
my boy lisa yeah i had ordered flowers
for my mom to be delivered saturday and
like nine o'clock i even told pause like
my flowers don't they haven't been i
don't have a tracking number yet
and i thought maybe since it was in
miami
they were gonna just overnight it and
deliver it that day but at midnight i
thought at midnight i got an email so
it's 3 a.m their time saying that they
weren't going to be able to get it out
and they re and they refunded it and
they're sorry
so i go crazy on twitter and then i just
ordered flowers what i'm going to do
from now on is just order flowers from a
local florist
but the youth of america i told you
before the podcast started you guys jump
on this [ __ ] that's cute
but at the end of the day
how effective really is it i gotta stop
and press a button just to do like i
totally uber you go outside and lift
your hand the cab shows up
but two [ __ ] want to make
everything complicated new york he's a
great kid he's great but lee loves that
[ __ ] computer he loves anything and
got the bid there on shark tank and they
don't get money lee really goes with
them
so well i i used them the first time
because they were sponsoring a podcast
right but um
yeah they slipped they were corporate
and they [ __ ] slipped and they [ __ ]
up the flowers or they got in too deep
probably they got in too deep see a lot
of those services what they do is they
don't have shops they call lee in boston
they go hi lee you're all quick florist
yesterday you have a three-star rating
on yelp this is what we do we're a
company we're gonna come to you every
month we're going to give you 50 more
business but we want you to discount our
flowers by 25
and what we're going to do is we're
going to keep 15
and since it's going to be 10 off or 15
off we're going to sell more flowers
than you are
what do you think can you do that it's
like people with that [ __ ] now when you
want a ticket to a show where do you go
groupon or whatever the [ __ ] you do the
same thing yeah
so you go to them correct this is what
you did with the flowers but that's all
great and dandy this is the service they
create so when you call them all they're
doing is shooting a [ __ ] email to one
of their centers right saying can you
send this it could be a mom-and-pop
[ __ ] florist the same flourish you're
going to use in your neighborhood right
that if you call them but the florist
gives attention to his business first
because his business he gets top dollar
of course he's cutting 15 percent off
his services for his jackalope so who do
you you follow me right yeah
no and then
the only reason i bring it up is because
i got an email this morning
from the ceo or someone who said he was
his ceo
and it was through their website and he
said
uh he said like i'm sorry
maybe maybe i could come on the podcast
and you could give me the like you could
give me [ __ ] i could explain what
happened
and i don't like i don't know how he
found that and then because yesterday i
tweeted when you're having your issue i
tweeted like books is the american
airlines event of flower delivery or
something like that i said he said the
books line hurt a little bit but it made
me laugh and i was like what is
happening like did he really think he's
going to come on here and like ftd gives
you points
if you use ftd you get points on [ __ ]
virgin and
you understand me
if you use hurts you get it's the same
[ __ ] thing right ftd has been around
since i was a kid and they're solid like
the rock of gibraltar like western that
are supposed to go local
local is ftd they're gonna do the same
ftd does the same thing i told you that
guy does only they've been doing it for
900 [ __ ] years
the guy with the torch with flowers in
his hand running through the [ __ ]
jungle delivering your flowers he's been
around since i was a little [ __ ] boy
okay
the issue with me yesterday was
basically this
i fly for a living ladies and gentlemen
and
i've been flying since the age of
[ __ ] six or seven
i used to go to l.a on eastern i used to
go to uh
to puerto rico in miami i'm pan american
and you know in the old days guys it was
about comfort and service
you got on a plane and if you had a
coach ticket you could buy an extension
and go upstairs
every plane had an upstairs this is why
when you look at a plane now you're like
what the [ __ ] happened
you just sit there
20 years ago you got on a plane and you
went upstairs once the seat belt sign
came on and you bought drinks at a bar
and there was a guy playing a piano did
you know that no and you could buy
snacks every flight every flight and
mingle on flights that'd be nice did you
know that did you know that bathrooms
and first class and other bathrooms had
stuff in it like creams that you could
use and tapes and it was just a
different world they don't have that
they gave they gave a [ __ ] about the
consumer they gave a [ __ ] about
you know they didn't waste your time
every week on
on facebook or on the news i got to see
about a plane that got left on the
tarmac for five [ __ ] hours
and people ran out of food with no heat
air on and people farting i got up
yesterday to pee in the middle of the
plane it smelled like an animal and i'm
not saying this it smelled like somebody
had taken their feet off somebody had
[ __ ] their pants
somebody had armpitted and it was all
together in the middle like from aisle
nine
to like i'll sixteen it was one of the
worst odors i've ever smelled hopefully
it wasn't one person no i don't think so
i think it was a conglomeration of
stinky [ __ ]
uh you know today we don't care about
nothing the corporate structure
has taken customer relation and they
passed the buck
this society is used to it but guys like
myself 50 year olds and 40 year olds are
not used to that yesterday in front of
me a 40 year old was telling her
daughter about what it was to fly 20 30
years ago
but not just flying
our whole complete corporate structure
when you call the phone person you spoke
to a phone person today a friend of mine
called me and said i'm gonna bind
can you send this money there for me and
i'll send it to you tonight right back
so it's in there i said sure
i called western union i couldn't speak
to nobody they kept messing up the
automated thing
oh yeah i just realized
i had to put money in my paypal and send
it to him
so my whole thing is
oh i thought the [ __ ] thing was going
off
you know this whole corporate thing it's
it's a pass-the-buck type of society we
live on and everything is very
time-consuming to the to the consumer i
think like all the corporations have
gotten together and said listen let's do
this every time somebody calls you it's
a 30 40 minute phone call you know
because then like that they just say
[ __ ] it and get frustrated and get off
the phone and hang the [ __ ] up that's
what most people do i'm busy so are you
i was on the phone once for an hour and
a half with att
when i tried to get internet with them
an hour and a half too and then some
people are charging now for you to do
stuff on the phone like let's say most
airlines most airlines if you like the
line yeah you get dirt can you turn the
air on it is hot tonight it's humid
but we're about to taste something else
we're gonna make my tape to caramel corn
now every 15 minutes we'll take
something today
until one man passes out
now i'll be fine place your bets
i get temperatures you're as tough as
[ __ ] nails lately you've been putting
down some numbers lately you're not
eating 30 milligrams no more you open it
up with 30 [ __ ] milligrams that's
what it's all about consistency that was
a very nice
thing that hegan machado said i really
thought about his statement about
consistency and it really is true
i could only go to jiu jitsu twice a
week
but i go to jiu jitsu twice a week
and that's it and i keep you know it's
like the podcast we keep this every
monday tuesday or wednesday that's how
we [ __ ] do it and that's so [ __ ]
important in life and to me
that's a great compliment
i love all that yeah i saw your eyes
light up because you've said that a
bunch about yourself i love it you have
to be this is the only way to move
forward is to let them know you're going
to be there at that place at that time
every [ __ ] week for them
so and i wanted to talk to you about
because i was thinking about a lot this
weekend
i have to go down and take a class like
there's no way
it'd be like if [ __ ]
i don't know larry bird was like hey you
want to come i can tell you some how to
shoot a basketball thankfully i can give
you basketball i think your life is
going to change
i don't know if i'm going to do it
forever but let me tell you something i
think the gap
the little thing that's missing in your
heart is some camaraderie thing you have
this and you have paula and you talk to
steve simone and you talk to me and you
talk to the agostino you talk about one
[ __ ] thing ten things with three
people
what jiu jitsu does what going to the
gym really does what you go to the gym
you get on the elliptical you put a tv
on
yeah you go there
you don't really want to even go there
to go there to see what working out is
really about
this weekend was great for me because i
forgot my ipod so when i went to work
out
saturday i had to do the elliptical for
30 minutes without the eyeball that's
tough and it lets you think
and this is what i've been telling you
from day ones leave that you go there to
put a stupid [ __ ] movie on
it's a stupid [ __ ] movie just go to
the think of who the [ __ ] lisa is on and
what your next move is
when you go to jiu jitsu when you go to
karate when you go to kung fu
after a month
people don't laugh at you
people applaud you for going even though
you sit in the back and you can't do all
the exercises everybody in that room
knows that when they went there the
first night
they couldn't do everything
right okay so
that's the beauty of martial arts you
know because of ufc and all this [ __ ]
we've forgotten the beauty of martial
arts
it's become we're using it for something
else
you know i don't use jiu jitsu to be a
tough guy man i really don't i never use
karate to be a tough guy i used karate
to let me know the things i couldn't do
those punches those breathings those you
always want to be prepared what if
there's an earthquake and you've got to
run out of your building when you're
huffing and buffing after six i'll be
the first one dead so what i'm trying to
say to you is
right now lee you have this
you have to do something else because
even when you go to the gym you don't
want to face nothing yeah i want you to
go to something it doesn't have to be
jiu jitsu you don't want to go here
machado i know how you feel you haven't
wrestled since high school you don't
know day one well guess what neither did
i i never wrestled
and i went and it showed me where i
needed work in my life and by me
covering those little holes
it helped me in other areas of my life
you're not going to go eight times a
week you're not going to go into
competitions you're not going to wait
live but that's today
i don't know what you're going to think
if you stick with it for a year and i
don't know what you'll think when you
stick with it for two years first of all
the drive yeah
you put your gear on you drive to and
fro
that drive again is with the radio off
it's a 20-minute ride for yourself and
even though you get aggravated you may
make a call or two
you're still thinking about your next
move in your day you're thinking about
what you're gonna go do you know what
last week
i learned an arm bar right from uh the
closed guard so this week i'm gonna go
try it but i'm also gonna last two
minutes today when i spawn two minutes
that's all i need to last i'll be fine
i'll let them arm you know what i'm
saying and every time you go you make a
little personal goal for yourself and
every time you go you push and you push
and you push and now you realize that
people are starting to join after six
weeks and now you're helping them
you're seeing people
that were you six weeks ago
right away you feel better that's the
biggest confidence you could ever have
in your life
when you think you suck at something and
now you're seeing people come in and
they're in the same shape of you and
they've been lifting they've been boxing
they've been jumping rope but jiu-jitsu
shape is jiu-jitsu's shape
it's different completely different than
what you've done
your core is [ __ ] everything you're
back
you know you're on your back breathing
and this breathing and this choking and
this learning your body's limitations
will help you sleep at night
it will help you in other areas of your
life like i said you think i joined jiu
jitsu to go to tournaments or whatever
maybe not today i just go to go twice a
week and to learn something and to
review something and if every week i
could do a little better than the week
before
i'm okay
if every week i could run one half a lap
or if every week i could run one extra
life or i could just do one hip escape
more than i did last week last week i
did seven this week i tried to do eight
[ __ ] i did six you know what when the
class is over i'm gonna do it
and then you do six again and you go you
know what i'm gonna do another six and
now you were supposed to do eight but
you did 16. you did three times eight
which is what eighteen three times eight
is twenty-four three times eight is
twenty-four yeah twenty-four i'm sorry
so now
you have you do twenty-four burpees
that's good there's so many different
variables and i'm not just talking to
you about jiu jitsu it could be shotokan
karate it could be judo and now
two days a weekly you don't talk to joe
diaz you don't have to smoke pot you
don't have to be the flying jew
you lisa
that's all you are wouldn't it be great
for two days a week that you just went
somewhere and you didn't have to tell me
where you're going just go on your own
don't tell nobody go on groupon see
who's ordering a thing you don't have to
go to [ __ ] keegan's go somewhere
where nobody knows you and i guarantee
lee you're going to call me in three
weeks and go joey i went to jiu jitsu
i [ __ ] love it it's so [ __ ] hard i
almost died but i went back and some guy
kicked me in the stomach by mistake
tonight it was so [ __ ] fun
and when people when you're on top of
people and people are teaching you stuff
and you're sweating on them it creates a
bond
it really isn't listen man and i'm not
preaching jujitsu i'm not preaching
karate i'm not preaching judo i don't
care if you take an archery class it's
that about you lee you're going to that
gym you're wasting your time yeah you
lost some weight we aren't doing nothing
you getting on there you don't think you
don't think of your next move you want
some stupid [ __ ] show community or
whatever the [ __ ] you're watching the
office i'm watching gladiator
what do you think you're all going to be
walking what do you think once the stand
master ends you guys are going to put on
the weight you got to continue growing
you got to continue doing something
because after paula has the child and
you get 40 you're going to put the
weight back on again the same way
[ __ ] i did so you might as well get
involved in something now that you know
when you have a child you can look at
paul and go
i'm going somewhere for [ __ ] one hour
to do jiu jitsu or i'm going somewhere
to learn how to do new checks so i'm
going somewhere to get out of your head
for an hour when i told the agostino
about his girlfriend he took it the
wrong way i tell you when we go do
conley when we go to work we go to work
if you bring your [ __ ] girlfriend
then you have to bring it all the time
the first time you don't bring her she's
going to say you're cheating on me
so you got to bring him you're going
there to work now instead of one
breakfast you gotta hawk up for two
instead of two tickets one tickets for
the movies you gotta go two when lee and
joey are having [ __ ] lunch you gotta
show up with your [ __ ] broad at the
table and you can't talk about dick do
you understand me you go to do a way to
go away not because you don't love this
woman not because no you go away to go
away to dig into your mind to write a
joke maybe a [ __ ] thought for 10
minutes you even know what what things
you think about when you're alone for 10
hours on a saturday alone creepy how
many times have i told you to get high
at six o'clock get a notebook think of
the ideas you get go to a coffee shop
even though you don't drink coffee stare
at these [ __ ] mutants drinking coffee
in the computers looking at whatever the
[ __ ] they're looking at it's very
interestingly and i told you when you go
over to that place yeah you lost the
weight but you haven't accomplished none
right you sit there and you watch some
stupid movie i like you i like wrestling
i think i'm gonna like you did too and
i'm telling you i never did it i don't i
don't like feet
i don't like people sweat i don't like
people nothing i'm just slow i don't
think i was scared i'm just slow to get
you so how long it took me to start
working out so but
and even if i end up going somewhere
right down the street from me i at least
have to go try it out with higgin like
that'd be crazy not to go oh my god you
have i had such a great time last
wednesday i'm gonna go this wednesday
i'm going ahead what time is it on
wednesday 11 o'clock
11 to 12 15 and we're back up the hill
at one o'clock nice and easy you stop at
jersey mike's now you eat a sandwich
with confidence i get the turkey
provolone on wheat bread half of it no
vinegar no i keep it light so it's just
carbs you know pretty much after you eat
cause
you're gonna go you're gonna sweat a
little bit i don't sit there you know
one thing about me is i know if i sit
there and get involved in eight [ __ ]
wrestling matches i'm not gonna walk for
three days then it becomes the law
diminishing returns i go there i do the
drills i do the exercises i jump up and
down i roll with two or three people i
tap out and i get my car and i go home
though okay it's very [ __ ] simple
back to the american airlines [ __ ]
thing here before we forget god sucker
all right okay how you doing kid i'm
doing great let's see the [ __ ] i tell
you what we'll do you wanna do more
yeah we're gonna sample everything my
god thank god let's sample the caramel
corn just so you see
this is a beautiful tell me tell me what
you tell me you're all the uh no gluten
no senses gmo
god 120 milligrams and it's 20 doses so
you're gonna live try this caramel corn
and tell me this isn't delicious and
we'll send the rest of paula okay so
what does it taste like what the caramel
corn is good like what thank you
taste it you tell me you be the judge
tell me that's not
delicious caramel corn just like you buy
the [ __ ] high-end caramel corn joint
what's the face for
i don't want to eat in the microphone
i'm trying to be polite [ __ ]
delicious
delicious nutritious vegan you know
this is auntie dolores the best when it
comes to these [ __ ] things
like i said all the edibles i get offer
a different [ __ ] bang to you i like
to mix them up i don't even like smoking
the same week two or three days in a row
i like buying a weed
i smoke it monday and i put it away till
wednesday and i smoke something on
tuesday i smoke something different but
i always got six different types of
wheat in the rotation sometimes i just
smoke it on one day and i call it i tap
the [ __ ] out you know what i'm saying
lee what's what the [ __ ] [ __ ] faces i
always wondered why you went to the weed
store so much because you go like every
day every day i go check it out maybe
they got something like a bigger because
like i just told you it just after two
or three joints i'm back to square one
it don't get me high no more so i like
to mix it up when i was a kid i'd buy
pounds and
it's i'd sell half of it and smoke half
of it and i saved a lot of money
but after a week i was smoking four
joints to get high i smoked 16 joints in
a [ __ ] day so i'd defeat the purpose
i could have sold and made some
baccalaureate you understand me a lot of
joints sure but that's how you roll even
then so
we get there
my flight is at 6 45. oh yeah
i get there at
5 30
which means you're up at what
afternoon i didn't even sleep i got back
from the hotel room the man on fire was
on from the beginning i ran downstairs i
smoked a joint i got a coffee at the bar
and i went upstairs and watched it did
not decaf
i watched it and i couldn't fall asleep
but it was okay because i slept 12 hours
a day before i prepared for this
i always try to prepare a little bit i
ate like a valium and slept from 9 to
12. it was [ __ ] tremendous so i
probably slept that night like
12 hours the day before okay that's good
so i was good i got up worked out ate
dinner and i did both shows and that was
my day
so i basically uh got there i had some
oh the breakfast was horrible don't ever
eat eggs that are not in yolk
at the airport i never eat scrambled
eggs like if i go somewhere and they
have egg scrambled i don't eat them what
are they they're powdered milk [ __ ]
water [ __ ] eggs like that subway
sandwich [ __ ] oh i would never get that
oh my god so the other day i'm starving
in michigan and i'm too early to do
radio so the only thing was opened by
the radio place with subway sandwiches
instead of supermarket
i got a [ __ ] egg sandwich on wheat
with green peppers and something else i
took two bites of it and i just threw it
away but at least i didn't pass out from
lack of sugar if i'm not eating you
following me it was so [ __ ] bad they
have those powdered they haven't already
made like i said i was actually i was
that one once and they nuked them yeah
at like midnight and they just pulled it
out from the back it's disgusting
[ __ ] disgusting it's pure cancer you
might as well jump in a river in jersey
you know what i'm saying you're gonna
get that's pure [ __ ] cancer
so i ate that drew it away and then when
i went to the bagel place on sunday at
the whole at the they were only at a
bagel place in mcdonald's so i went to
the bagel place i was going to get all
the bagels with stominky bagels so i
ended up getting a [ __ ] plane with uh
turkey and cream cheese and a tomato and
it held me because i don't want to get
on a plane and have a problem
and it helped me
we get on the plane we board the plane
at 6 15 first class upgrade no [ __ ]
drama
nice seat second it's cold on the plane
i put my hooded sweatshirt on i'm ready
a nappy noodle
there's been a maintenance problem get
off the plane
the plane's going to take off at 10.
okay so we take off at 10 [ __ ]
o'clock
we get on the plane we're in the air
about an hour and also nothing comes on
there's tornadoes in the area we're not
going to land in dallas we're going to
land in wichita kansas
so we landed in wichita hills kansas or
some [ __ ] you got to see this airport
beautiful no food just two vending
machines and two [ __ ] gates they
won't let us out
i saw [ __ ] tsa sit down for maybe two
hours without a customer
okay and a cop was in that they wouldn't
let us out of the building no food i had
beef jerky
beef jerky had a bag of [ __ ] uh
trail mix that's what i ate balanced
lunch we sat there for three hours
from there
we took off to dallas we got to the tarp
we sat on the tarp for [ __ ] two and a
half hours
i got on the airport at six o'clock you
should have seen those desks they were
packed there was bad weather but ours
was a maintenance problem that if they
would have had fit my beef was this why
don't the mechanics come in at six and
warm up the plane and check the plane
before the plane takes off you're going
to tell me once you get on the [ __ ]
plane that's lack of professionalism
especially for the [ __ ] plane the
amount of money we spent for plane
tickets i called you last week tell
these people what's going on to go to
boston in june like 700 bucks 700 bucks
with taxes it used to be 300. how much
was virgin
six you told me we had some 580 580 we
talked about guys that's a lot of
[ __ ] money i hope you have cruise on
24 hours that are inspecting these plans
might as well okay so they cross off the
flight you know
now two hours
fueling they hit you with that fueling
thing i never seen planes fuel so
[ __ ] much did you get from dallas
tell me we were at wichita for three
[ __ ] hours now on a tarp for two i
get in it's [ __ ] packed since i had a
platinum thing the lady goes go to the
ambassadors club whatever the [ __ ] it is
admiral's club where burke chrysler
drinks himself to death
and get your ticket rewarded or they'll
give you a hotel room between me and you
guys i just wanted to come home i got to
leave on wednesday go do that [ __ ]
video game up in san francisco
i just wanted to come home and spend
three days with my family was mother's
day
now i'm on the tarp do you know i didn't
yell on the tarp i didn't do nothing
first off i went prepared
i had two things i have nasal spray i
had one [ __ ] uh
green hornet and i had two cheaper juice
you know me
and i found a vapor pen with half of
that stuff in it the juice left oh yeah
the the dab in the vapor pen
so i was hitting dabs at the airport so
i was tuned up
at the airport at six o'clock i was so
[ __ ] tuned up and i hadn't eaten
so i looked on the board and i saw that
there was a seven o'clock it was 6 10
when i landed in dallas there was a
seven o'clock flight an 8 10 flight an 8
30 flight with a connection in phoenix
and a 940 flight
i looked at the gate where the 940
flight was and i rushed there
and everybody was on that line for an
hour dog so three hours in the tarmac
two at the [ __ ] airport all the way
around
and two hours early now i'm an hour
standing online and i got american
airline calling me back within an hour
and a half to two and a half hours they
told me they're going to call you right
yeah
i get up to the [ __ ] thing and
they're like talking about tuesday
morning
but there was a flight at 9 40 and since
i had to upgrade the first class ticket
in the platinum level
they said we'll try to get you on
standby i said tell me right now if i
could get on that's the last flight if
not let me go to a hotel room the lady
looked me in the eye she goes you're
getting on
okay i went and got barbecue at dickies
which was terrible with some cheese and
some [ __ ] uh coleslaw i think the
coleslaw was the best thing on the
[ __ ] dish i mean i ate half of the
barbecue meat
two or three pieces of macaroni and
cheese and i just walked around stone to
the gills
i fueled up the phone you know so now
what do you think happens at 9 40. we
line up at 9 10
and as we're gonna go board there's
something wrong with the [ __ ] plane
no no no no the stewardesses didn't get
here
what
so just go you don't need drinks so now
we don't board
until 9 40.
the third store that shows up
okay we sit on the plane for 20 minutes
we're ready to board
there's a maintenance problem we
de-board the plainly
now we wait a half hour
it's 10 o'clock
i'm not coming home i'm in dallas
now we wait a [ __ ] hour and then they
held out that they switched the boarding
gate to something else i gotta run get
on a [ __ ] train
and go get over there on that plane
we get there what do you think they tell
us like
move back we're waiting for a stewardess
another stewardess what happened to the
store this is from the other [ __ ]
plane well since they were assigned to
that plane they can't come on this plane
guys you have no [ __ ] idea this is
american airlines okay then guess who
comes trotting along that's tourist the
three stool is from the other [ __ ]
plane
sun they bought us and then before we're
about to take off they go listen just to
let you know
they didn't do a maintenance check on
this plane the light just came on i got
it handled if the light comes on again
we got to go back and do maintenance and
that might take two hours which means
three or four hours which means
you might as well make till six in the
[ __ ] morning yeah
but everything went i landed at one
something
when i landed i was smart enough because
those flights were earlier i knew my
luggage was going to be there so i ran
to that area everybody else ran to the
luggage thing and i'm like you guys were
at the airport for five or six hours
your luggage is already here
i saw my luggage by the escalators i was
walking off i went right for it crossed
the street got in the car and i drove
home my wife cooked
i ate i stayed up till like 3 30 in the
morning i couldn't even fall asleep i
was so [ __ ] tired that's a long
[ __ ] day man that's a long [ __ ]
day so i wrote my grievance today i
wrote what i wanted and let's see what
happens that's great that's when i went
to like the uh the wedding in vermont
and at the wedding they canceled my
flight i had to drive to albany they
gave you what
what do you mean you said they gave you
points or something like that they
didn't give they didn't give me [ __ ]
they gave you guts you got to ask delta
just gave me like 5 000 points for a
flight they [ __ ] up so what i wrote to
american airlines was it was a
mechanical problem
you know you can't have that many
mechanical problems when i'm paying the
money i'm paying for the plane tickets i
understand there's bad weather and i
understand that people have bad days
this was just too many bad things
happening to us
it was one thing after the [ __ ]
another you know i was waiting for my
luggage not to get there or for the car
not to stop it was one of those days
but you know what man i went to michigan
for five shows i had a great time some
people gave us a lottery ticket some
people [ __ ] took care of it some guy
sent you a card yeah thank you where's i
want to be around cox put that on a
little music there it's monday may 11
[ __ ] get out there wash your
helmet
i just realized how much i love tony
bank this morning
dustin's a wacky thank you
we'll do it again the proper way
that's into whacking uh-oh you know what
time it is
time for an edible lisa what are we
doing next so what do we have we have
brownies so far and we've had the
caramel corn
do you want to do a cocoa sparkle cookie
nope let's do a cocoa sparkle cup i
can't do anything yes you did man
there's nothing look it's 10 milligrams
look at it i can't go look at my face
it's fine look at your face
one more we're going to do that we'll do
a piece of pretzel and then we'll call
it like that one like this
oh my goodness and this is a cocoa
sparkle cookie 200 milligrams
vegan low glycemic this is good for you
eat the cookie lee please we're doing
this
way embarrassing
auntie delores worked hard to send us
this on the [ __ ] arm look what she's
done to me so far huh look what she's
done to me so far
listen the pretzel the caramel corn is
not even eight milligrams this is five
yeah you don't even have 120 in you yes
i did
you're light
you're liar
i take care you leave i got your back
how delicious is that gluten-free
chocolatey
nice
you don't taste the weed in this thing
i'm not tasting much of anything right
now joey that's good that's what he's
supposed to do we don't want to take
nothing anywhere you don't want to have
a guilty conscience
something really weird going on at the
house
let me give some shout outs real quick
i'm going to talk about this okay i want
to give my man martin a shout out for
the lottery ticket we didn't win dick
but brother i love you thank you for
coming to the grand rapids show
my man todd lightly
larva whatever your [ __ ] name is
uh
wait till dust wait for dust
no nick my man nina samuels
my man harry henderson my man jose
guyton
and matt and winnipeg i love you
[ __ ] with all my heart people
what are you getting about you already
gotta listen [ __ ] like a little kid what
am i gonna do which i hit you in the
head one of those 86 cigarettes
something weird has happened in the
house i haven't talked to you guys in a
while a personal level
after [ __ ] i put [ __ ] down
about five days later i had to put my
cat fidel down who i had for 13 [ __ ]
years
fidel was just a great cat my wife is
still shattered
in fact it was saturday that a week we
put him down and saturday i was thinking
about my mom because it was her birthday
and fidel was more overwhelming i
couldn't believe how much i missed fidel
i miss his walk
i looked at a picture of him and he was
just a [ __ ] beautiful cat but he lost
like 18 pounds like he was small dan he
was very tiny he wasn't him he was a
shell of what he was
fidel was a great cat fidel would if you
didn't sh if you [ __ ] in a little box
and didn't cover it up fidel would whack
you and then he'd cover it up and whack
you in that come find you and whack you
fidel was very loving he was very gentle
uh
he was the first cat to mess with me
yeah fidel loved everybody if that would
jump on your chest and rub your face
with his face he just meant well he
loved damon i called damon
and told him your buddy how to put him
down damon was in shock fidel was just
i've been very blessed with great cats
and they got problems but they're great
cats and i always felt that
when you give an animal love you know
you give them nothing but love and you
you're honest with them and you [ __ ]
they love that they do anything for that
[ __ ] and fidel was just one of those
guys
and the deal was we're going to put him
down on monday
but sadly when we got back from swimming
with the child he was in the litter box
half and half out
he wasn't even strong enough to come on
the cat little box my wife asked me we
started talking about him we go let's
take him down
my wife was broken for two [ __ ] days
my wife loved that cat i mean it was so
sad and i loved the cat with all my
heart we lost two cats in one week but
as fidel was me and my wife were talking
i looked at my three boys and i said
it's about to go down
you feel like the king of the house it's
a power struggle and now it's going to
be a power struggle you got
two cats already that don't like each
other
and super bad always attacks demi every
[ __ ] night at some point i hear them
struggling and demi doesn't like super
bad at all didn't really yeah demi
doesn't like it he's a nice guy timmy's
very nice but he just doesn't like super
bad super bad gives him the [ __ ]
creeps
you know when superback comes next to
him he gets up and comes by me it's a
very weird thing so i i didn't know it
took a while you know it took him about
a week to notice that fidel was gone
and when i got in sunday night my wife
was telling me oh my god it's been a
hell of a week we're done fighting
jimmy's got a scratch on his face
harry's got a scratch on his face harry
fought oh harry fights super bad three
times a day
sweetheart no harry and super bad have
been like the dylans and the mccoys who
are those people from the sounds of
mccoy i feel they've been like that
since day one they just don't like each
other and every time they [ __ ] get
around each other their hair stick up
but my wife said it's been horrible like
before it was just two scratches and
they both go to their corners now
they're tangling i haven't seen them
tangled yet but today i saw something
very weird for years super bad's been
taking demi
for years super bad's been just too bad
to [ __ ] street savage he's just tiny
but he's a dirty streak super bad when
you pick super bad up and you look at
him and you kiss him you're like i love
you super bad but you're a [ __ ] dirty
[ __ ] street cat his head is tiny his
body's big
he's just a warp little [ __ ]
that has a lot of heart
and i love him he saved me so i i can't
throw him to the walls but he's not my
ideal [ __ ] calorie year nothing like
that he's not no he's a [ __ ] dirty
ass [ __ ] but that's why i love
him he's got class
so uh
today something happened [ __ ]
jimmy was on the couch and super bad
jumped up like three feet from them
and demi just went over and swallowed
them the super back cow down which in
any other day of the week super bad
would [ __ ] attack
and i saw last night that super bad and
harry were having a problem and superbad
hid behind the [ __ ] thing
because it's basically about age it's a
anarchy of age like a an aids thing you
know so
my wife said that demi and gray got into
it too the other night
but gray hates demi you know gray
[ __ ] hates them it's so weird how i
look at these cats and i learned to see
their different personalities
but i was looking for the power vacuum
and it's
it's what really baffles me lee that
this happens in corporations
that's how primitive we are what happens
in corporations okay so
uh you're a college guy you just came in
from college and i've been there for 10
years
and also i'm one day the [ __ ] ceo of
whatever comes in and he says
i'm quitting
okay
i'm giving my resignation this has been
great but i'm gonna go work at nbc
right away you put your [ __ ] antenna
up and you go home and tell your
girlfriend
that your opportunity is here you're
gonna take over this division i go home
and tell my wife i'm going for it and
then there's some [ __ ] pipsqueak
in accounting that he's been there
longer than you and i
and he wants that position
so what happens
uh a slight but subtle
thing starts like a little war very
slight very subtle but it exists it's
there you know a tension between people
and then it's the ass kissing the who
works later hours it's terrible yes it's
terrible but it shows us how primitive
we are then you have the side of the
street you have drug dealers and mafia
kingpins and russians and everything
same thing happens
some guy goes to prison he doesn't
appoint a [ __ ] nobody who goes to
prison wants to appoint somebody i'm the
boss i'll run this thing from prison no
you're not you're going to run it from
prison but you still need somebody out
there to run that [ __ ] operation for
you okay okay and and boom when there's
not somebody
there's going to be a problem
because even if okay so let's say i
gotta report to lee
i like that even if
even if
just by me reporting to lee
that puts me in a different hierarchy so
i would come to my guys and go listen
give me your envelopes i'm going to
report to uh lee in prison
there's probably going to be two people
who are pointing to lee in prison and
one other guy like a son
that's telling them what's really going
on because i'm going to go up that thing
with a story and he's gonna go up there
with a story because eventually the guys
that are dealing with you are gonna get
the next call to be you
uh
so now it's one against the other but
that same exists with cats
one cat dies the elder one like when
demi died fidel had to fill his void so
fidel became more vocal
it was really weird demi was always very
vocal
finney was always very vocal when finney
died
fidel became very vocal to the point
where you wanted a [ __ ] strangle yeah
but you loved him so much but he became
very vocal because he thought that's how
he had to act
and i saw this and i was like baffled on
how [ __ ] much
you know our how our brain works from
the smallest level of cats
it's crazy how involved you are and it's
because you have you spent a ton of time
with those cats like when you're up late
at night by yourself
like you like you know your cats like
when i had when you asked me to go feed
them you're like okay you got to put
this bowl here but make sure it's this
bowl not just any bowl because so-and-so
will only eat over here it's hysterical
and you gotta mix these two together and
like you like listen they're not gonna
eat if you don't put it there so please
put it there and
like you just know if you miss
harry will not eat anywhere else
there could be food in 10 bowls i will
not touch it if it's not by the cabinet
fidel wouldn't eat if it wasn't by the
garbage by the door by himself
the girls they eat together the boys eat
together
that's just little quirks cat have but
it shows me
that you have a choice as an animal even
you know what i'm saying like
how cool is it that these [ __ ]
like i'm not eating out of his bowl this
is my bowl i want it right there
i i remember fidel [ __ ] crying
because his bowl would be under the
cabinet instead of buy the garbage can
he wouldn't eat
wouldn't [ __ ] eat he just wanted to
be by himself no he wants it to be by
the garbage can
i've learned so much about the cats that
in turn it's helped me learn about
myself
like when i first had the cats i would
go home at night and get coked up and in
the middle of my coke up i play with the
cats
that was my entertainment i'd be a
little paranoid but i'd be petting the
cats and by petting the cats it would
control me
it says that people what's the statistic
that people who own cats
or animals live a lot more yeah i'm sure
you know now in prison they're giving
cats to inmates that's what i see on
msnbc
when i got those cats i started really
thinking about quitting blow i got to be
honest with you because
i was so involved with them when they
came in that i knew that the coke
and their involvement and my comedy and
all the other [ __ ] i had going on at the
time
it fills a void man those cats really
fill the void for me they help me take
my mind off a lot of things i owe a lot
to those cats
i
you know i i can't give them
i can't give six cats well now you know
whatever we have but i can't give six
cats attention
20 minutes each a day i don't have it
but every day i spent time with one or
the other today it was lulu and then
super bat you know today it was lulu i
got on my hands and knees and i kissed
her and i brushed her and i rubbed her
stomach and she was so excited she was
meowing hard she started to purr when i
would scratch her back you know and in
turn it relaxes me man it's really
calmed me down it's really uh
i don't know it's made me a better
person having a pet
and that's why i advocate having a pet
because i i understand but there's
people who get pets and can't take care
of them yeah everybody's got to be on
the you know you have to be ready for a
pet you know when you're ready for a pet
you're like you know what i got some
security i'm ready i have a partner i
have a plan you know well it's crazy how
many people don't because like when i
was looking for a dog i went to the
pound a few times there's a ton of dogs
there
and then down by where paul lived
there's a ton of stray dogs
it's crazy it's [ __ ] great i couldn't
imagine just abandoning an animal
i don't know how they live with
themselves
you know uh years ago when the stock
market fell and people losing their
homes that was the biggest complaint
that people were leaving [ __ ] animals
behind and
i don't know i made a commitment
before i made that commitment i really
thought it out and you know me you've
been around me for a couple of years now
i don't even like taking vic i don't
like me and my wife gone together right
yeah it spooks the [ __ ] out of me
because it makes me anything could
happen to these animals i don't want
them i love these animals if i was gone
in aruba i can't even relax
knowing that they're alone that
somebody's coming in when i always
actually take care of them what do i say
to you sit with them for an hour yeah
watch tv put the tv on they love all
that [ __ ] they come out and they'll play
and you get on you and next thing you
know you had plans
i don't know how many times i've had
plans to just play and also the next you
know i'm there an hour on the floor with
that and i'm having a great time when
demi used to when i used to put the
notebook paper up and diddy would run
through it
he would yeah like like uh you know
like a bull fighter yeah when demi was a
kitten he would run through the paper
and he would run through it run through
him three broke it in half well i'd do
that 80 times broken
and when he broke it in half i'd go get
another [ __ ] piece
you know they're entertaining it's great
to get a dog today i was getting my hair
cut and i heard about a lady who
saved the dog on google 405 somebody
dragged the dog and left them for dead
i wouldn't know what to do i wouldn't
know what to do i knew i think i'd fall
apart if i saw a dog in that shape i
really would cry and you know when i see
cats getting hit with squirrels and
they're still half alive
it breaks my [ __ ] heart if you're
gonna hit a [ __ ] animal kill him do
me the favor kill him don't drag him
down the corner and let them [ __ ]
live in that pain with a broken arm how
about i do that [ __ ] [ __ ] to you you
know if you're gonna be a [ __ ]
criminal i'd rather you kill the animal
and leave it there for [ __ ] dead and
then somebody gets stuck with a thousand
dollar [ __ ] thing and the cat's
walking with a limp and a [ __ ] cane
the rest of his life
what's up lisa what's up in your world
[ __ ]
uh i have a
i'm trying and i want i wanted to talk
to you about i'm trying to pitch
to tv shows
that they should have a companion
podcast
and i've been on a couple meetings and
like they liked it
but
they're having a hard time understanding
like where would be helpful like they
were like how could we do like a lot of
episodes like they didn't understand it
beyond interviewing the different
departments
and like i have
another meeting wednesday but it's cool
because
i met this guy on periscope like he's a
producer who's been
saying like
hearing tv pitches so i emailed them and
we have a meeting but i think
what it's going to take is like someone
to understand social media to be able to
do it
and it's just it's kind of weird like
how many times have you pitched
something and you think it's like a
great idea but no they just don't
understand it well they they find the
holes
and it's like everything else like i
told you the other day on the phone
when you pitch something it could be
anything
i don't care what you're pitching
the the
the nucleus of this whole thing makes
you a sale
yeah you're selling me your dream you're
selling me your idea
so what you have to do is you have to
write the advantages and then within
yourself look at the disadvantages you
know when somebody when somebody builds
a great alarm what do they do
they go to prisons and they get the best
[ __ ] burgers in the world
it's the best
and they're paying when they go i want
you to break into my [ __ ] house for a
hundred thousand dollars i'm gonna give
you a hundred thousand dollars you have
to steal not just break into my house
and they look for gaps in their game
before they present that alarm and what
the offers are
they do that okay you ever see uh what's
the movie with charlize duran and uh
italian job italian job in the beginning
she's cracked safes you know she taught
you know
that's
what was i talking about
i'm not exactly shocked
as far as i was with you though
what are we talking about selling stuff
so selling stuff so you have to look at
it
you know they want to see what the holes
are in your game
you're a young guy so you look at the
advantages of it let me tell you what
the disadvantage tell me the
disadvantages of it though the
disadvantage of first order when you go
in there
what did i tell you a couple weeks ago
about clubs that don't know about a
podcast right it destroys my insides
because this is what's feeding your
electricity bill this is what's keeping
your lights on right now six or seven
guys that have podcasts that are coming
through here and the fans come out they
smoke weed they eat
podcast to me if you don't know what a
podcast is right now shame on you i know
people will say you know what i've never
listened to them but i know it's like
something like a radio show right boom
okay we're halfway there
okay so now you have to let them know
the advantages what are the advantages
of having
this [ __ ] podcast let's say you went
and pitched uh does the walking dead
have a podcast
yeah not an official one but they do
that's why it's is it the cast members
no it's not what this is is it the
nerdist
no it's uh after buzz tv and i'm sure
they're nice people i know i've never
met them
but i did some research because uh i
used to work for hell's kitchen so
that's who i was pitching to so hell's
kitchen has one through them but it's
like a radio host
interviewing people over the phone it
doesn't even sound good and
that's not the point like the point of
it would be to have the host of the show
or somebody involved like a past winner
i liked what the sons of anarchy did
sons he had a post show the problem with
the post shows they had a terrible
[ __ ] host
and they had it on the air and
you tape it half the time you got to
realize that 60 percent of the people
are taping it well those people that do
even on it those are the [ __ ] podcast
people you want so if i was kurt sutter
for fx what how would you what would you
pitch kurt sutter after season three
you'd say have a podcast where because
in 22 minutes you can't really get into
a good discussion if you could have one
writer on okay no see that's where you
[ __ ] up you're gonna go in there and
the first thing you gotta do is explain
the podcast
explains what it does for the careers of
20 [ __ ] people not even joe diaz
explain what it's done for adam carolla
yeah and how joe rogan and how marc
maron that's what you have to sell oh i
said that okay no you didn't you have to
sell that
and then you have to [ __ ] get a list
of tv shows that have a podcast and tv
shows that don't
okay you have to do research lee and you
got to see what the differences is in
numbers
and then how is this going to
advantageous to you and you have to get
a show that they have and already have
the podcast planned out so let's say you
were pitching kurt sutter or the
executive at fox you'd say okay so we
need a common host
somebody who's not on the show that
interferes that's where lisa comes in
okay or anybody else just a regular guy
that's a fan of the show
that'll be the third voice to hear from
and you have kurt
sutter and you have one of the people
that were in that episode right and
right after the show or on this set
while you're shooting it
you could you stream it and put it up on
whatever or fox net it you know they
probably have they make this [ __ ] look
like [ __ ] you know
and that's what you do and you release
that
the wednesday morning after the show
airs on tuesday night i'm just taking
sons of anarchy here ladies and
gentlemen that is your plan if you do
that okay
what is the advantage to the show how
many viewers am i gonna get more than
what i'm doing right now if i sink three
thousand dollars a week into this lead
which is 12 grand i'll get sponsors to
cover it i'll get fox and i'll get
[ __ ] uh big time people
how is this going to be advantageous in
my show tell me
i think you'd get
more
more viewers you get people who will
just find the show but then what i think
the best part for you is
is
maybe not that year maybe six seasons
down the road because what you get when
you have a common host or you have
someone who's invested in it is people
get invested in them
i have so many [ __ ] cool people with
me on the podcast
that if i was gonna go do something i
know they said they'd support me they'd
support us if we ever did a kickstarter
if the show
the show's goal
is to get extended there was a bunch of
cancellations this past week
you don't think so you're not selling
the podcastly you're selling okay you're
selling garbage that's what the problem
is so what do you say how many numbers i
want numbers what the [ __ ] is how much
how many more viewers am i going to get
from the podcast there's no way to know
that no there's no way to know that so
this is what's going to happen you got
to sell them the advantage if they don't
have the podcast
that don't have the podcast right now
anybody can have a tv show but america
has grown over the years they want more
they want social network they want more
yeah we applaud that charlie hunan and
all the [ __ ] people have twitter and
that's great do they do it themselves we
don't [ __ ] know they're making 80 000
a week what the [ __ ] they care about
twitter but we need a common ground for
people to tap into maybe listen to one
of the guys talk about acting maybe how
he got involved in acting maybe his
story is always a great guest star you
know they had [ __ ] the player or
whatever but what what what happens if
they don't have a podcast as a salesman
what's next the pretzel
what happens if they don't have a
podcast
people will the show get cancelled
yes no it won't yeah what you're going
to say
what you're going to sell them what
you're going to sell them
and i don't know i'd have to think about
this
don't want to know numbers
always talk to viewers when you go to
those meetings people talk numbers when
i saw sports information on the phone
i didn't talk numbers i took the money
the bottom line
that bottom line is getters how are we
going to make gears on this show
why am i taking two hours out of my week
to do this [ __ ] podcast for a show
you know duncan trussell
always says that if he was on a tv show
he'd do his own podcast every week yeah
because he communicate
with the viewers to make your bond to
the viewers yeah strong so when uh in
your season four when [ __ ] breaking
bad two comes on or hanging out with
saul
your people don't leave
right and they're they're actually doing
podcasts by the way there you go so
that's your [ __ ] leg up now again let
me ask you a question
because breaking bad was a success
okay this show that he had this [ __ ]
gilligan [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah the show got
canceled obviously because all these
idiots think that once they do one they
could do 20 and they think they're
[ __ ] special and geniuses and they're
[ __ ] not stick to one show what the
[ __ ] you know this guy did breaking bad
did he have well podcasts weren't around
when breaking bad started they were more
popular towards the end right but let's
call saul who does the podcast them he
does it he does it and he has other
guests on the the the actor vino vince
vin diesel
ben gilligan vin gilligan
i would love to have vindica
when gilligan does the podcast himself
yeah that's genius yeah and that's what
you have to sell right there that's a
guy that saw a vision that's the guy
that saw a view let's compare let's look
at
let's look at and now you have to break
down shows let's look at what a spin-off
does in television
look at it with those spin-offs on all
tv shows that have been around and see
what they do if they last
and compare the numbers and see what the
numbers are on soil right now and that's
what you're selling the podcast on there
you go
okay so you have to do the research on
what's been on show so let's say there
was a show called married with children
there was a spin-off to the sick i see
what we were saying and seeing how that
show did and compared to how who the
[ __ ] do you think if you're gonna be a
salesman lee you gotta sell money
and percentages to tv people yeah if
you're going anywhere
this [ __ ] kid though you know if
you're gonna do a ten thousand dollar
presentation if you're not gonna sell a
ten thousand dollar thing with a ten
dollar presentation right i want your
presentation to be tip top i don't want
you going to another pitch meeting
unless your presentation when you go in
there you got to be prepared from a to z
you have four points and the last one
the whole time you're always closing
okay
so after each [ __ ] tidbit you tell
them
you're gonna tell them what's gonna
happen to that show if they don't
[ __ ] get a podcast and you're looking
straight in the [ __ ] eye and the
person who talks [ __ ] loses and then
you go into your [ __ ] stamina
speech and again you let them know again
this is what's going on so your first
one you tell them the history of the
podcast and the shows that are existing
in the podcast
and then you're going to tell them why
their show should do a podcast and
they're going to tell them what'll
happen if their show doesn't do a
[ __ ] podcast okay
and then you're gonna pitch the podcast
to them you're gonna tell them who's
gonna do it when and how and when it has
to be up
okay because don't let them think of a
[ __ ] original idea none of those
[ __ ] have had an original idea
since 1962. they're [ __ ] dummies and
when i tell you you have to go in there
assuming they're [ __ ] morons because
that's what they are
you know how many people are not on
twitter how many comedians after the
success of twitter and podcasts still
refuse to do a podcast with twitter but
still sit there and [ __ ] uh you know
tell you how you're lucky youtube
whatever how many of them how many
[ __ ] people how long will it last for
that's what you're selling and if you
sell it with that passionately you'll
get it right now you only pitch once or
twice you're not gonna sell not in your
first two pitches unless you're [ __ ]
johnny rotten
you're learning the ropes you're
learning the objections
if this is what you want to do there's a
show out there needs a pot modern family
do a podcast
uh not an official one okay so
uh
now who does the nerdist do a podcast
for i thought he did the show after
uh that [ __ ] show with zombos and
[ __ ] on amc nah
the walking dead yeah well he did he did
a tv show
okay it was a tv show so the same thing
podcast tv show i guarantee that i would
get more people to download the podcast
than that after [ __ ] show that's
another thing
yeah no i want you to go in there with
the numbers i don't want you to tell me
but you can't
i don't have access to anybody's podcast
you got them make up numbers go in there
make up [ __ ] numbers okay make up the
debt that what do they know either
they're gonna leave and go to the office
and check they're gonna be so blown away
from your [ __ ] thing that you could
sell on whatever the [ __ ] you want you
could tell them 18 92
in 1983 when this show came up with a
sequel or a [ __ ] spin-off these were
the numbers the show lasted two years so
far now what makes saul that much better
they're living in 2015.
you're selling 2015. not 2008 because
they don't know lee
and what do people do why don't you go
to jiu jitsu why don't you lift weights
lee
because people who are scared of things
don't want to try them
right i got to leave so when you go in
there you got to think from your
perspective
how many times is joey going to tell me
to do [ __ ] push-ups or to lift the
[ __ ] dumbbell just to do something
different and i don't do it
you're going to have to sell it from
that perspective to them why they have
to do the podcast
and that's it that's the pitch
i pitched a lot and i always left with a
hole in it i remember these guys
approaching one time
and they wanted to pitch a detective
that had a martial arts school
and he worked with the mayor behind the
scenes it was a great idea but they
wanted me to wear a kung fu suit to the
[ __ ] pitch like a chinese one where
they roll up and i refused to do it
because i said this is you're using the
prop to close a tv show
that's never worked
you got to sell money
and how this is going to [ __ ] profit
you
with the least same thing when i come to
you what do you want you want more money
for less time
and how is this going to affect you lee
three years from now your show
will not get cancelled
because you develop a bond with the
public
they have an email where people can hit
emails up from the thing this is a
complete social media thing you're going
to put a complete social media together
you're going to work closely with their
social media department
and that's how you sell this thing thank
you because they don't know what they're
doing and they don't want to deal with
anything
they think you're going to call them up
in two in the morning and say hey the
ustream was down
they don't want to deal with that they
want to go to their parties and ha ha
and in a year when the show's successful
they'll take the
yes that was my idea to put the podcast
for the show right yeah
so what's the story next week in
[ __ ] you coming to las vegas hell
yeah you bringing paula no you're coming
by yourself are you staying at the south
point with me sure let me get your room
yes yeah that'd be cool
talking there's going to come a little
discounted room san diego's going to
come we're going to eat [ __ ] pasta
you're driving sure are you really
yeah you can't you can't get a ticket
now i checked there's like 300 and then
i was like there's cash one way one way
no no i i found round trip today from
burbank really yeah what
southwest really but it was just like
then you have to get a cab to the south
point
i might as well just drive i like
driving no if you come with me
one friday morning the south point will
pick us up take us right down to the
junkie
what's up what time friday morning 6 30.
okay
see if it's still available i will
look at you you're going to gamble no i
can't yeah ooh i'm excited though i have
a i had a bet that on the patriots doing
the super bowl so i want 100 bucks all
right so talk to me about this talk to
me about what happened today i went to
the gym
and i saw that they suspended tom brady
for four games for the deflated ball now
who suspended them and who did this
investigation because i knew nothing
about it i thought that they was dead
six months ago no they were pissed off
uh
they had this guy we're doing a little
piece of the star that's just complete
that we've done one two three four
five different edibles tonight at least
i don't know that and we're still
standing like soldiers this is why i
love you
you got [ __ ] clash you got style you
got mink and gordy got personality
thanks
what do you think you're dealing with
this is the [ __ ] podcast i wanted but
we got the best of what we got on the
monday night we got the message
we wanted to level out with you people
because we've had guests the last
[ __ ] eight things tomorrow we got
sebastian montescalco at 1 30.
so get ready for that lee we don't have
to get high tomorrow right i don't
believe you
so someone write someone note the time
on twitter it's 9 33
and what tomorrow at 1 30 you're gonna
be like here have a place sure but it's
tuesday tomorrow i don't know what i'm
gonna feel tomorrow right now i'm not
gonna feel like getting high tomorrow
especially after the smorgasbord
but tuesday tomorrow's the [ __ ] 12th
yeah
no
something happened
something [ __ ] happened we got a
celebrated league so you don't know what
happened to him they got suspended four
years well they lost two draft picks
they got fined a million dollars yeah
that was like the highest ever fine i
don't know if he did it
and the report only said he probably did
so they didn't even they couldn't prove
it but he i mean he probably did
but i i think don't they usually appeal
and then maybe his suspension will get
cut by two games
or something
i didn't listen to the guys what they
were saying i just seen it come on big
screens and in a way
now i feel bad for people because when
that [ __ ] white boy comes back and
starts throwing darts after those four
weeks it's gonna be scary themselves
suspending them for four games it's like
throwing [ __ ] gasoline on a bee's
nest and it's good because you're old so
like it could be good to save them for
four games yeah before getting to get in
the playoffs
who they got those four games let me
check
i saw who they had those four games i
think the raiders somebody else it
really doesn't matter i usually don't
talk football on here but [ __ ] it this
is something that happened today a lot
of people like tom brady i'm a fan of
tom brady's i don't pick lee you didn't
eat the pretzel i'm way too hot no no
you gotta eat the pretzel the pretzel's
the last thing on the [ __ ] thing and
we'll split this green horn and then
we'll go home like gentlemen what do you
think and we'll do a cavocate of things
tonight why yeah the pretzels three
milligrams
they're [ __ ] my friend's favorite in
jersey
first four oh oh no see what you got
here what did they get what oh okay well
we got
well [ __ ]
okay so we start out with pittsburgh
which is not good
buffalo which is not looking not good
then we got jacksonville which is fine
and then we have a buy
and then we have
dallas which sucks
so
yeah it's not an easy four games
who gives a [ __ ] well people are very
excited about you putting those things
on youtube
you know uh
you had to put them on lee well yeah it
was just like you got i don't care who's
taking them down at least give them the
opportunity yeah we just got we got
locked out of our account and so we just
got back into it and then i put them up
sometimes they get taken down but they
should all be up by my gmac account from
the from the youtube from the website
got closed i don't know what happened
over the weekend i tried to switch it
over and i lost if he's trying to send
me an email i haven't reanswered your
back it's not that i don't love you so i
can't [ __ ] get to it i don't know
what the [ __ ] i'm gonna do or how i'm
gonna do this you might have to come
over tomorrow and tell me what the [ __ ]
to do
so uh if you've emailed me i know my man
noah from the agency tried to contact me
about a book and was supposed to talk on
friday i opened up my email this morning
was gone uh danielle sent me a [ __ ]
email that he said he sent me an email
so please if you uh sent an email
recently to beauty uh the church on on
the website
uh joeydears.net and i have an answer
it's not because i don't love you
because i can't [ __ ] get to the
goddamn email so
yeah so but yeah we're in it what
happened to the president i don't want
to hear that come on come on can we
split it no i already ate ten of them
let's go what split just throw it down
like a soldier that's a three milligram
pretzel these are all novels dude thanks
ladies
we're not even that high you're really
not
you're really not think about it
you know
you're high on the
see look how nice you are see how nice
and the guy just hit me up from anarchy
edibles we're picking up new stars
a bunch of little stars of debt so we're
back they were fueled up constantly and
i just want to know like i said before
these guys don't sponsor me these guys
don't pay me a [ __ ] dime they send me
the product i sample this stuff you know
people send me vapor pens i can't really
mess with vic depends because i have
nailed their life as a sponsor and
they're my vapor pen of choice so i
really can't help you with vapor pens
but if you have an edible and you want
me to try it let me know i'll [ __ ] go
to the store and buy it i'll let you
know my true [ __ ] review but don't
show up with some [ __ ] you better show
up with something 300 milligrams or 200
milligrams that's [ __ ] knock the mule
down don't waste my time if you're
[ __ ] around i don't want to eat a big
cookie that'd be funny
goldfish the smaller the better we go
for little things that are atomic you
understand me it'd be funny if someone
gave you a bad one and then you did like
a bad review i gotta get a bad review i
can't let [ __ ] people eat bad [ __ ]
edibles every edible i [ __ ] talk to
you people about i stand behind 150
percent i don't eat they don't pay me
anthony dolores is a sweetheart my
mathematical edibles i love the [ __ ]
deck he's got a great brownie ladies and
gentlemen anarchy edible not only has
the [ __ ] stars they have a tremendous
chocolate [ __ ] rice krispie treat
they have a tremendous chocolate brownie
they have a what's the matter lee
you look like somebody cracked the
[ __ ] funny i didn't say nothing funny
you [ __ ] yeah
uh chiba chew has a tremendous green
horn for the money one of the best
edibles out there i think they just
raised the price i like them at 10. uh
deca the deca dose white one is great
the decades green hornet which i gave
lee tonight it's also great it's like 9
000 milligrams no it's only 75
milligrams as you can see i'm only lit
line
you know these are products that i eat i
rotate them so i don't get used to them
and i don't get spoiled so i'm not here
to lie nobody these are not they don't
pay me a [ __ ] dime okay i still have
not reviewed the uh axis roach clip 300
because we never [ __ ] bring a roach
up here so that's the next thing we got
to review they want to do something
we're going to give them like an episode
brought to you by axis 3000 type [ __ ]
okay okay yeah look on your face like
you just smelled the bad [ __ ] what is
it lee talk to me guys i'm fine i'm just
super duper high that's right it's
monday night everything's beautiful
everything's great you're gonna go see
the agostino kansas city barbecue and do
something no i can't eat barbecue i
didn't say they eat barbecue i see
you're gonna go over and look at the egg
you're gonna go over there and say hello
who's gonna go to a barbecue place every
monday they [ __ ] pack where you going
you get a beer and a sausage is that too
hard to understand to comprehend
you want to go over there and say hello
okay
okay
you're not going to go you didn't even
bring your car you're [ __ ] over how
the [ __ ] you got to stop with this uber
[ __ ] who picked you up tonight
this is weird dude
he's like a really old car he looked and
still had like the
manual windows and
it was a bad it was a bad one but you
seen the back seat are you sitting next
to him in the front seat back seat
how'd the back seat look
it was clean it was just old
how much did i charge you
440. how much you give them
four you can't give them anymore no tips
they don't have it on the app now
why
because they don't i don't know lyft
lets you give people tips
now what's the difference between lyft
and [ __ ] nothing to two different
companies and lyft is good too and these
are people with their personal cars yeah
lift is a little more expensive
but now it's it's crazy people are like
there's like a business growing of like
you can rent a car by the week
and then you lift or uber with that car
like so people are like renting priuses
people are making a lot of money doing
it you just have to be out there for a
[ __ ] long ass time
pretty [ __ ] unique how people are
making living driving people hey it's a
hustle man yeah and you work for
yourself right or uber takes a pc action
they take twenty percent
so a 440
you bring home [ __ ] three something
but there's a dollar safe ride fee so
yeah that we don't get i don't know what
the [ __ ] that's for
and you get the rest so 260. so you get
260 for you know how many [ __ ] rides
you got to give for 260.
that well when i did for like those few
days the only good ones were like the
far ones who sent you a check did they
send you a check yet yeah yeah they do
direct deposit
really right then when it happens yeah
well every week
once a week yeah
very interesting see people if you're
hurting for some money watch the [ __ ]
back seat put some stars put some
[ __ ] little
those little christmas trees back there
that smell good one dude who picked me
up here had a lexus had a cooler with
sodas in it and had an ipad for you to
use
people are getting really creative with
it it's really cool
no [ __ ] yeah it's a way to do it free
sodas yeah free and the ipad was stapled
to something yeah or you picked it up
you know it was like attached to the
headrest and what are you going there to
see he said it was cool like the girls
like doing it with photo booth and then
they take pictures of themselves and
then they can send it to themselves
very nicely yeah that's pretty cool you
learn something [ __ ] new every day
brother thank you thank you for i don't
know nothing about that [ __ ] lip but now
the people that live in the area could
get a [ __ ] lift if you're [ __ ] up
like we say what are we eating next week
we gotta eat something else
one last thing what are we gonna do
before we tap off a cyanide pill no
let's do uh some of the star death for
the anarchy animals let's see oh thank
you i love you guys but
look at this this is still fresh we got
the seal a meal
two weeks in what do you think lee
i think it's crazy let's eat this little
corner right there you
what do you mean no thank you
what's going on what dude what i've had
like 400 milligrams maybe you have it oh
yeah
you had 75
75 and 5 is 80. that's more than five
twenty and eighty is one oh five
one ten
and one twelfth that's what you had
tonight you could do a little edible
black okay what the [ __ ] we're going
beef time
what the [ __ ] this is delicious it's
fresh
what do you think you're dealing with
here look at this it's [ __ ] beautiful
crazy person
i'll give you a little piece that's my
little piece look at that you guys look
what i'm dealing with i'll give you a
little piece right here how's that
look at that i don't want to do that
either that's not even five milligrams
cut it down
right look at this look what i'm
throwing down that's another hundred
like i told you if you're gonna go deep
we gotta go deeply so yeah we ain't
[ __ ] around
this ain't even a reefer podcast we just
[ __ ] around here like gentlemen
let me get you a pizza
huh you're in the mood for a pizza and
some garlic yeah i know you're in the
mood for some bad [ __ ] pizza it was
good which one
danielle's
what's danielle's the place i sent you
to
the brick oven please not bad the cheese
is delicious the crust is what you got a
problem with this we got extra cheese
oh [ __ ] it was all over the place
how many slices she four
lee
lee split
she ate four and you ate four she only
had three and you ate four what'd you do
with the extra piece i threw it away
[ __ ] animal thing all right
[ __ ] we'll be back tomorrow wait
we're into it we're gonna do ads right
now i'm just talking to these people
relax where the [ __ ] are you going cox
is that gonna make with my glasses on
right now we had a great beautiful
podcast we just discussed what was going
on in our lives i'm sorry i just dropped
the cat thing on you guys i didn't want
to talk about where he was here or the
other guy uh
fidel it happens you know i'm not really
that upset i just
you should have just seen the face
believe me he's just he's scared to go
home now he just went i gotta go home
and get high anyway
for total optimization i love these guys
i took them yesterday after my 12 hour
[ __ ] day this morning just to get
rejuvenated alpha brain is [ __ ] great
i went to the gym today
and i did i had to do my lower half
which is dead lifts a couple squats a
couple the machines the hack machine
some extension then i got on the
elliptical
and i took the uh
the uh
shroom tech sport today i took two of
them i gotta tell you something i felt
like a [ __ ] savage today by the time
i got in the elliptical i was already
[ __ ] drenched from the dead lips and
i just started sweating and my shorts
had circles on
from the shirt dripping on the
thing
i stayed on five or six the whole 20
minutes man i just moved on it i must
have burned like 400 and some calories
today and that was the [ __ ] shroom
tech i'm telling you for people this
[ __ ] works you know i haven't tried the
new mood in a while you know i do the
180 when i fly like yesterday when i got
back last night i tried the 180 and i'll
tell you i was up for a little while
with the jet lag but i [ __ ] fell
asleep and i felt great that i had no
effect i'd have to take a nap today i
did a thousand things today on it is
great that's what i'm telling you i
think aubrey was on joe's podcast today
he's always trying to develop new things
he's always adding things to pills and
taking them out and just because you
know he knows
they got to offer they got so many
[ __ ] things supplements they've got
the battle ropes i can't get you hooked
up on that as far as supplements i'll
get you ten percent off i want you to
try them if you're working out just try
shroom tech just try it one [ __ ] time
go to honey.com go to the box and press
in church when you're on an insurance
tech and get 10 off all right just try
it
if you're going to the gym you start
you're struggling with breathing or
whatever they can't help you with that
that's what i thought shrew tech was
going to help me with
what it has given me is a little bit
more gas tank it's given me a little bit
more energy which i never knew i don't
drink energy drinks or nothing like that
so please go to honor.com go to the box
and press in church boom and get 10 off
and if you want to stay on it i'll mail
it to your house in the first of the
month every [ __ ] month all right my
people hit these cigs
just doing a great job when i'm on the
road this week i brought like two of
them from my hotel room i brought the
one cigar and one uh 16 milligram
nicotine they're [ __ ] great 1200 pups
they're always coming out strong listen
i got no complaints about 86 if you're
thinking of quitting smoking you want to
try a cigar that you got go to 86.com
right now and press in joey's church and
you get what 20 20 [ __ ] percent
of them so it costs 20 you get it for
16. okay go to 86.com they make a great
[ __ ] product
1200 guaranteed pups go to 7-eleven buy
one of those cigarettes you get like six
[ __ ] pups all right
and for what for 10 bucks this is 16 and
you're gonna get [ __ ] 1200 guaranteed
pups go to the [ __ ] box right now go
to 86.com look at the selection of
cigars and cigarettes they got go there
press them what leave joey's church boom
and get 20 off again my main people dave
[ __ ] foley making it happen
over there at iron dragon tv
i think we're gonna do a sample run next
week um back for the week with aldo i'm
gonna call all the things me and all
don't wanna do uh a couple of these
movies and do the iron dragon tv but
always the leader in classic martial art
films these guys aren't [ __ ] around
all right every week they're adding new
[ __ ] films go to
irondragontv.com right now right now and
get two free martial arts [ __ ] films
even get them now for the weekend just
get them what are they pressing the box
joey joey you get two free [ __ ]
martial art films they got they got
rogan on there talking they got uh
honored videos on there it's not just
about that man this is another company
that i love what they do because they're
trying to they specialize in 4k
technology they're the leaders to the
leaders in 4k technology hopefully they
get the ufc contract their films look
great all that classic martial art films
it looks that much better but [ __ ] it
[ __ ] what jungle joey says go to iron
dragon tv right [ __ ] now go look at
what they got to offer press in joey and
get two free films all right enough is
enough again for my reefer heads i love
you [ __ ] suckers i'm not here to blow
smoke up your ass nailed it life.com the
best vaper pet on the market tremendous
guarantee i know these guys their
[ __ ] family i know their family from
north bergen and west new york 30
[ __ ] years ago i went to tweedy's
[ __ ] wedding in fact he got off
parole today thank god after 22 years he
put it on facebook after 22 [ __ ]
years his parole ended today for that
thing when he was throwing the coke off
the plane that's how we roll we hang
with people that throw coke off [ __ ]
plants you understand me congratulations
go to nailed it live.com right now look
at this great selection of stuff they
got they got everything net for you in
the dab world these guys are a leader in
dabs every time you see them they got a
bag full of [ __ ] naps go down and go
to nail the life dot com and press in
joey diaz and get 20 off the pen right
20 out of the vapor pen one of the best
baby pens in the market full [ __ ]
guarantee they answer your calls all
right another shout out to on it hitting
six iron dragon tv
and nailed the light martin for the
lottery ticket and you guys for
listening and for loving us and for us
for loving you [ __ ] had a great
time in grand rapids las vegas is
[ __ ] next [ __ ]
what [ __ ] i'll be at the store tomorrow
on saturday night what [ __ ] i'll be in
oakland shooting a video game whiskey
what what what lee what's up buddy what
else are we
nothing that's it we're tapping out for
the night i love you guys with all my
[ __ ] heart thank you very much for
listening tonight you know we didn't
want a guest tonight we just wanted to
chit chat and just uh catch up i think
next week we want to call my man dc
we'll call a couple of [ __ ]
next week all right what do you think
lisa i had let's do it how are you doing
with your little [ __ ] frantic
mushroom shirt on
i'm good
all right wrap it up i love you guys
have a great [ __ ] day tomorrow we'll
be back tomorrow at 1 30 to rock your
world oh and then
can we say about uh the website talk to
them later okay what's going on so
next monday
may 18th we're gonna switch over
you're gonna go to joeydears.net live
slash live tap knock on that link and
that's what we're coming on we're no
more you stream we're gonna rock the
[ __ ] world all right we're gonna
start promoting on thursday
every hour on the iowa on twitter let
you guys know we're coming on a
different thing we're gonna uh give this
a try
so get ready rock have you tried it
already is it right we've tried it but i
want to do guys like later this week
try like look for me on twitter i'm
going to do a test because i want to see
what's what happens if a bunch of people
start going on
but
sounds perfect i love you [ __ ]
stay black uncle joey here for you
[ __ ] always
go to onit.com and use codeword church
to get 10 off of all the great
optimization products like alpha brand
new mood swim tech and mainstream tech
sport
go to irondragontv.com and use cobra
joey to get two free rentals from all
the great martial arts movies and the
leader in 4k
4k technologies for all the oil and wax
smokers out there
for the premier vapor pen on the market
go to nailed it life.com also los gumi
hermanos and you're you're going to get
20 off the vapor pen with cobra joey
diaz
and
i'm going to hit e6.com better tasting
longer lasting the proof is in the vape
they have e-cigarettes in these cigars
for you twenty percent off and use
covered joey's truck what are you
giggling about don't forget i'm in
oklahoma city may 30th
crank that [ __ ] lee
little give me shelter for you
[ __ ]